ah
en la vida y las cosas que tenemos claro
uno no puede tenerlo todo y otro el que
mucho abarca poco aprieta están de
acuerdo
pues no
yo estoy convencida que si puedes
tenerlo todo y que quien dijo que yo
quiero apretar algo si puedo abarcar
mucho
de hecho no sé quién fue la primera
persona que comenzó a decir esto y todos
los seguimos repitiendo hasta creer la
verdad y eso nos limita yo creo que si
lo puedes tener todo
para esto primero hay que definir por
qué es todo para ti
y después hay que quitarnos esta
búsqueda inalcanzable de perfección
porque buscando la perfección en todo lo
que hacemos es como nos hace sentir que
no lo podemos tener todo y la perfección
no existe
nada en absolutamente nada yo creo que
dejando de buscar la perfección es como
te atreves ir por todo por todo lo que
tú quieres y que nadie te la cuente ya
como te vayas otra historia pero va pero
vas por ello
yo siento que las mujeres en donde más
tenemos ganas de ser perfectas es en la
maternidad si tú me dices
como que tu coche no es el mejor te digo
no pero me lleva a lugares si me dices
pos profesionalmente no te veo siendo un
móvil ni presentando tu película en
cannes te digo no pero ahí la llevo pero
si me dices como que eres una mamá
bueno
y no es ninguna explosión con lo que te
vas a caer encima
yo tengo tres hijas que en redes
sociales a la grande le digo la infanta
maría y bueno con ella todo salió
perfecto no como lo que te dicen que
debe de ser la maternidad
me embaracé ya también pegaba cositas en
la panza y posaba en bikini
me sentía increíble trabajaba lleva
clases de lamas de yoga prenatal salía
con el marido en la noche me sentía
plena hermosa una de las mejores etapas
de mi vida yo podía ver un año
embarazada como elefante sí que se queja
en qué belleza
obviamente fue parto natural
agradeciendo cada contracción cuando
nació se sacó la calificación a buscar
10 de 10 porque los humanos nos gusta
calificar nos hasta literal cuando viene
saliendo el útero de tu madre
lactancia materna exclusiva el elixir de
vida por siete meses la niña salió
rosada que acetona y con ojos grandotes
bajo muy hermoso
y en esto cuando me sentía muy salsita
que me chicharrones truenan y le daba
consejos a mis amigas de cómo hacerle
porque yo sabía de qué lado masca la
iguana
me parece de mis gemelas de los choco
twins así es no una sino dos huertas
metidas aquí adentro
y entonces hice un vídeo de cómo me la
estaba pasando en esos momentos
[Música]
no encuentro no encuentro mi celular
y
[Música]
también podría ser villeta a no haber yo
voy a ver
son tus hijas
[Música]
por favor
no no no
[Música]
no
h
[Música]
e
él
[Música]
aquí en taquilla y atajada yo con este
vídeo lo único que quería era
desahogarme lo subí a facebook y para mi
sorpresa tuvo más de 6 millones de
vistas
al parecer había muchas mujeres ahí
pasándola de la fruta
y esto a mí me hizo darme cuenta de lo
necesitadas que estábamos las mamás
de ver contenidos en internet que fueran
reales que no fuera pura belleza y pura
bendición sino si lo es pero también es
unos riesgos
y bueno aquí estoy un día antes de parir
a mis gemelas hinchada harta acalorada
desesperada y al día siguiente nacieron
no
una de mis bebés nación super chiquita
y mis planes no salieron no salieron
porque eso no era mi plan mi plan era
también tener a dos niños iguales que la
primera porque la primera me salió bien
lo que pasó
idiomas ya culpa porque yo sentía que mi
trabajo como imán como mamá era que he
visto eran sanas y llevarme las a mi
casa y tener mi famosa importante para
mi lactancia materna y eléctrica en gurú
y todas estas cosas y mis planes no
salieron
y aquí es donde me dio la afamada culpa
de madre yo sentí que me atropelló un
camión o sea tenía demasiada demasiada
culpa demasiado sufrimiento yo decía
algo y semana al wilstermann debí de
haber guardado el triple reposo debe
haber comido cinco veces más proteína o
me divierto parado de cabeza para que la
niña que estaba acá le llegara más
comida no sé
claro que antes ya había sentido esto
fuera mucho menor escala
pero aquí yo decía no estaba consciente
el término como tal pero me sentía un
fracaso
me sentía muy mal me sentía triste me
sentía sola que aún y que mi esposo me
apoya mucho
siento que no llegaba a entender
completamente por lo que estaba pasando
aquí es un videíto de cómo me la pasé en
los primeros me dices
el viento
[Música]
pero no
y bueno aquí obviamente está actuado y
esto lo subí a instagram porque para mí
es importante
plasmar lo que vivo a través de la
comedia y de esa manera conectar y sonar
lo que está pasando adentro
lo que si no le pude sacar comedia ni
subir a internet fue cuando karol ha
estado en el hospital si ve en mi mano
chiquita y se ve en oro me he comprado y
como estaba ella pues son kilos 600
gramos o sea se han comido un bistec más
grande de lo que haya nacido
y entonces yo me iba y la visitaba
y le escribí a los poemas más trabajos
del músico y le cantaba y le rezaba
y lloraba el valle de lágrimas de que yo
allí y en una de esas jamás se me va a
olvidar qué
que llegó la mamá de una de las bebés
que estaba también ahí en cuidados
intermedios
y me pregunto cómo estás
y entonces yo me puse a llorar no y yo
estoy súper frustrada porque hoy bajo
gramos y cuando me lo voy a llevar a mi
casa de ansiedad y lloré y lloré
llegó ahí cómo estás tú
y me hice
ayer le dio un infarto cerebral a mi
bebé
y yo me sentí súper pont no llorando por
gramos y su bebé tuvo un infarto
cerebral y su vida estaba en riesgo
me sentía punta y tenía pena y no sé
pero en eso me abrazo
y las dos lloramos juntas
y me di cuenta que no había juicio en su
parte que lejos de haber juicio ya
empatía que las dos queríamos lo mejor
para nuestras bebés y que estábamos ahí
juntas
aquí la primera vez que la cargué
lo primero
[Música]
lin carola
dijo
y bueno me la entregaron y dije ahora sí
ahora sí te lo voy a compensar ahora sí
llamaría de 17 meses pecho a ti un año y
medio y te voy a traer colgada aquí como
canguro y me compré una manta de esos
que te amarras y dije ahora sí hasta que
cumpla 15 años de estar ahí preparada
yo tenía muchos planes muchas promesas
de campaña
que no pude cumplir no pude cumplir
llegué a mi casa
y estaba ahí y echándole muchas ganas y
yo trataba y trataba y nada más estaba
frustrada exhausta y de pésimo humor
pero dije ya ya tengo la respuesta no
pasa nada
plan b le voy a hablar a una asesora de
lactancia de esas que te enseñan en
tándem a una bebé en cada bubi y voy a
hacer la diosa de la lactancia
generaciones van a hablar de mí porque
van a ver ahora sí
y entonces vino beer y la asesora de
lactancia y me encontró
ha hecho trampa
me odia odiaba la vida pero sobre todo
me odiaba a mí porque mis expectativas
no las estaba pudiendo cumplir yo estos
parámetros de maternidad perfecta que te
dicen que es lo que debes de hacer y que
aparte leí que los niños que entran la
incubadora les marcaste la existencia
van a estar solos en una caja para toda
la vida sintiéndose abandonados y yo con
mis planes de tratar de compensarlo no
estaba no estaban saliendo
y entonces ella me enseñó
una lección muy bonita que quiero
compartirles
me pidió que cerrara los ojos
me agarró de las manos y me dijo que me
regresar a ese lugar donde yo le prometí
a carola todas esas cosas
y que le dijera que la iba a amar
siempre y que le iba a dar lo mejor de
mí
y con eso
yo comprendí que que la maternidad es
mucho más bonita y mucho más compleja
que cumplir con ciertos parámetros con
ciertas ideas preconcebidas que leemos y
repetimos y le decimos a la cuñada y a
la hermana y lo subimos a twitter ya
instagram y que es mucho más que eso
bueno fuera que la maternidad fuera una
receta de un pastel de zanahoria donde
pones paso 1 paso 2 paso 3 igual a tu
pastel no es así la maternidad es
hermosa y es totalmente imperfecta
yo sentía que a maría le había dado un
lamborghini y que a mi ley a carola les
había dado un vocho madreado
pero comprendí que no es así que nada
más fue una maternidad diferente y que
eso está bien y que el tipo de
maternidad que lleve cada persona es
distinta y a su manera es perfecta
y también estas ideas preconcebidas se
remarcan con redes sociales porque ahí
estás sin bañarte con diez kilos encima
apestando con las bolsas y que no
aguantas si no entiendes como ar petri
te metes a instagram y ves a mujeres que
lo tienen resuelto que pesan 40 kilos
después de parir que tienen andan en
tacones en las piedras que sonríen y que
tienen y que tienen la vida resuelta y
se la saben todo y eso solamente
refuerza la curva que hay atrás y sacas
tu hijo y te empiezas a dar entonces a
mí me gustaría invitar los que realmente
nos cuestionemos todas las ideas
que vemos que leemos que repetimos que
no nos traguemos todo lo que nos dicen
de como debe de ser algo porque no es
verdad
y bueno la culpa de madre atacada duro y
cuando menos te lo esperas
como los alcohólicos solo por hoy porque
cuando crees que ya estás del otro lado
te hablan del kinder de tu hijo y te
dicen que mordió
o te dicen que tu hija es divina pero
que no tiene amigos
o voltea si la ves y no tiene el cuerpo
de bratz que tienen todas tus amigas a
mi me da cuando trabajo de pronto cuando
estoy grabando una serie o salgo fuera a
dar un show y sacó otra vez el latido
pero ahí está mi esposo para recordarme
y cuando me veas y me dice
si a lo mejor no estás para cambiar cada
pañal
ni para meterlas a la cama todos los
días
pero le estás enseñando con el ejemplo
que pueden lograr todo lo que ellos
quieran que si quieren ser arqueóloga
son rockeras poetas si quieren ir a
marte con hilo en moscú
y quieren tener un esposo y se les
antoja tener unas hijas lo pueden tener
que no tienen que escoger sólo una cosa
porque alguien les dijo que el que mucho
abarca poco aprieta yo también digo que
hay que reírnos del proceso y porque ya
estás en eso y entonces cuando a una
noche a las tres les picó un [ __ ] y las
tres estaban vomitando y estábamos mi
esposo y una mano nos encontrábamos de
medio pasillo con una niña vomitara
metiendo la bañar y yo decía ni en mis
peores noches de fiesta de acapulco
había visto tanta acción y tantos
vómitos
porque hay veces que ahorras un año para
irte de vacaciones porque vas a gozar
vas a descansar y vivir la vida y
resulta
lo único que pasa es que una niña odio
el mar la otra se mete arena al ojo y
luego se lo quitas y se vuelve entrar en
al ojo una seta enferma y atrás y tienes
que traer a un doctor del pueblo de al
lado y lo único que quiere decir que tu
casa porque hay conocen sus cunas su
rutina y tú sientes que alguien te dejó
una lana porque esa cosa
no pudo ser gratis
pero nadie te cuenta eso tomo una semana
más la foto de las tres niñas divinas y
el caribe atrás
y entonces hay que reírse de todo el
proceso yo creo que reírse y platicar lo
es como los sanas los sacas y encuentras
empatía en otras mujeres
bueno estamos muy guapos y bueno hay
ciertas cosas que me gustaría que se
quedaran de esta plática que es número
uno no está sola no está sola tener una
red de apoyo es importantísimo que el
papá de sus hijos y está presente haga
su chamba como tú haces la tuya
puedes buscar ayuda de tu mamá de tu
suegro de tu vecina de la mamá del
colegio que te cae bien no te hacen
menos mamá al pedir ayuda
y sobre todo que no te sientas sola que
cuando digas me siento tonta porque no
he dormido en tres días y no dejó de
llorar que cuando no entiendas que algo
no te salió porque el niño no deja de
llorar y tú ya te vas a tirar por el
barranco no te sientas sola hablándolo
llorando lo sacando lo encuentras una
empatía grandísima de muchísima gente y
que vemos muchas pasando por lo mismo
que estamos tratando de hacer lo mejor
que podemos
sin llegar a ser perfectas que si puedes
tenerlo todo nada más tienes que saber
que es todo para ti
que la perfección no existe no existe en
nada menos de la maternidad cuando
tienes a dos niños de dos años que
atentan contra su vida cada cinco
minutos
y que se esté en la culpa de madre ya ya
por favor todas hay que dejar ese látigo
a un lado que si hay que
responsabilizarnos pero sin sufrir sin
dolor porque eso no trae nada bueno que
la hora en que tú te quieres más y
disfrutas más de la maternidad que
aparte pasa rapidísima cada etapa
vas a ser más feliz y si tú eres más
feliz
tus hijos también van a ser más felices
porque la vida no es perfecta y no eres
feliz porque porque no es perfecta es
que esa es la belleza la vida es
imperfecta y ahí está el gozo la
diversión
y lo más padre que es muchas gracias
[Música]